Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Roberto Minelli
Quando inizio a parlare
di diritti delle piante,
in genere c'è sempre qualcuno che ride.
Qualcuno sorride,
qualcun altro proprio si spancia.
Forse mi vedono con i cartelli
a marciare per il "flower power",
per i diritti dei gerani,
o i diritti dei cipressi.
A dirvela tutta, non è neanche detto
che prima o poi non lo faccia.
E spero, anche,
che il giorno che deciderò di farlo
molti mi seguiranno.
Studiando i diritti, però,
quello che ho scoperto è che
questo atteggiamento è del tutto normale.
Così ho smesso anche, per inciso,
di rimanerci male.
Perché un secolo fa si rideva
pensando, per esempio,
che le donne potessero votare
o che potessero fare
dei mestieri molto difficili,
come pilotare un aereo o fare dei giudici.
E due secoli fa, anche meno,
le persone di colore venivano
considerate quasi degli oggetti,
venivano considerate proprietà
dei loro padroni,
in alcune parti del mondo,
proprio come oggi consideriamo le piante.
Il punto è che i diritti -
che ci sembrano qualcosa
di immutabile, no?
Ci sembra che debbano sempre rimanere
quelli che conosciamo noi -
in realtà li ha inventati l'uomo,
ed è con la società umana che si evolvono.
E quindi cambiano nel tempo,
è normale che ci sia un'evoluzione.
È difficile abituarsi all'idea
che tutto piano piano ci scivola di mano,
e che tutto piano piano
è destinato a cambiare.
Ma è proprio così che vanno le cose.
La cosa che deve però confortarci
è che, ogni volta
che noi attribuiamo dei diritti
a qualcuno che non ce li ha,
creiamo un mondo più giusto,
creiamo un mondo più uguale,
creiamo un mondo più sicuro.
Un mondo dove, alla fine,
poi stiamo meglio anche noi.
E allora ci deve, secondo me,
fare molto riflettere -
così è capitato a me -
il fatto che da questo mondo,
da questa scoperta dei diritti,
da questo grande ombrello,
sia esclusa una così grande
parte della vita:
oltre l'80% della biomassa,
cioè di tutto quello
che arriva sul pianeta,
non ha dei diritti.
È difficile, così, avere un mondo giusto,
è difficile avere un mondo equo.
E allora io, per aiutarmi
in questo piccolo viaggio
che voglio fare insieme a voi oggi,
in cui voglio parlare di diritti,
ho pensato che ci volesse proprio
qualcosa di vegetale per aiutarmi.
E ho scelto qualcosa che mi somigliasse.
E sì, effettivamente c'è una somiglianza:
ma non è quella che pensate voi.
Tutti assomigliamo alle banane!
Sapevate che abbiamo più del 60% di DNA
in comune con una banana?
E già solo questo dovrebbe farci pensare
che la vita va in un modo un po' diverso
da come l'abbiamo immaginata
fino ad adesso.
Comunque, ho scelto
questo aiutante un po' speciale
con lo scopo di farvi
immaginare insieme a me
un mondo in cui il ruolo delle banane
sarà veramente cruciale
e veramente importante.
Ma visto che vogliamo
parlare oggi di diritti,
direi che è fondamentale partire
dalla Carta Costituzionale,
dal posto in cui tutti i diritti
di uno Stato sono riconosciuti.
Sapete che la nostra è stata riformata
a febbraio di quest'anno?
Un piccolo passaggio
negli articoli 9 e 41,
dove sono state aggiunte poche parole
che però hanno cambiato un sacco di cose.
Nell'Articolo 9 si legge, ora,
che "Lo Stato tutela l'ambiente,
la biodiversità, gli ecosistemi,
anche nell'interesse
delle future generazioni".
E inoltre "disciplina i modi
e le forme di tutela degli animali".
Secondo me è una bellissima cosa,
ci voleva assolutamente:
eppure manca anche qualcosa.
Gli animali, d'accordo:
ma le piante dove sono?
Eh, le piante non ci sono:
ce le siamo dimenticate.
Ed è una grossa dimenticanza.
Anche perché nel mondo, intanto,
le cose stanno andando
in tutta un'altra direzione.
Questa storia inizia nel 2008,
quando uno Stato sudamericano, l'Ecuador,
include, per la prima volta al mondo,
nella sua costituzione,
i diritti della natura.
Li chiama diritti del "buen vivir",
cioè del vivere bene.
Perché, dice, si vive bene
soltanto se si è in armonia
con tutte le altre forme di vita.
È l'unico modo che ha
l'uomo per stare bene.
È una grande rivoluzione, che inizia così.
Sembrano soltanto delle parole,
naturalmente, no?
Una bella dichiarazione di intenti,
da mettere nella Costituzione.
Invece nel 2010 arriva un altro Stato.
Questa volta è la Bolivia.
Guidato da un nativo, da un indio,
per la prima volta in assoluto.
E anche la Bolivia inserisce,
all'interno della sua costituzione,
i diritti della natura.
La chiamano “Pachamama”.
Perché è la dea, la madre generatrice,
è la natura che informa
tutta quanta la vita.
In fondo siamo tutti quanti
delle forme di vita:
La vita è una, che poi assume
tante diverse forme.
Questa credenza è molto diffusa,
tra le popolazioni native
di tutto il mondo.
Questo animismo un po' diffuso,
che ci unisce alle piante, agli animali,
ai fiumi, alle foreste:
siamo un tutto indistinto.
Pensate che adesso, circa 20 anni dopo,
esiste perfino un Tribunale Internazionale
dei Diritti della Natura.
Anche se, purtroppo, quello che fa
non ha valore legale,
ha un valore di forte indirizzo
per l'azione dei governi.
È stato un continuo,
è arrivato uno dietro l'altro.
Adesso questa, per esempio,
è una petizione per i diritti dei fiumi.
Uno dice: vabbè, riconosco
il diritto di un fiume;
ma a che serve questa roba qui?
Continuano a rimanere sempre parole.
Allora, io vi voglio raccontare adesso
la storia di un fiume.
Un fiume che sta in Ecuador,
il primo paese che ha riconosciuto
i diritti della natura.
Questo fiume si chiama Vilcabamba.
Allora, dovete sapere che se in Italia,
o in qualsiasi paese europeo, per esempio,
un fiume viene inquinato,
e io, che sono una cittadina
di questo paese, subisco un danno -
per esempio, sono un contadino,
innaffio con l'acqua del fiume inquinato
le mie verdure, e muore tutto.
Quindi ho avuto un danno economico,
porto in tribunale l'inquinatore,
e se sono molto fortunato
vinco il processo
e ottengo un risarcimento economico.
Cioè, il fiume è inquinato;
e io, vengo risarcita.
Se invece il fiume ha dei diritti,
come è successo al fiume Vilcabamba
che è stato inquinato in Ecuador,
chiunque - perché il fiume è nostro,
il fiume è di tutti,
quell'acqua lì è di tutti quanti -
chiunque di noi può andare in tribunale,
portare in tribunale l'inquinatore:
e se vince la causa,
sarà il fiume ad essere risarcito
e ad essere ripulito.
C'è una differenza gigantesca,
una differenza epocale
che è destinata a fare, senz'altro,
un grande cambiamento
nei diritti dell'ambiente.
La chiamano, infatti,
la "Giurisprudenza della Terra".
E se prima erano
soltanto due Paesi sudamericani,
e in tanti l'hanno liquidata dicendo:
"Vabbè, sì, è una cosa degli indios,
una cosa dei nativi",
ecco: adesso ci sono gli Stati Uniti,
la Nuova Zelanda, l'India.
Vedete, è veramente un fenomeno
che si sta diffondendo ovunque.
Ovunque tranne che in Europa,
perché ho il sospetto che nessuno di voi
ne abbia mai sentito parlare.
E in effetti, è successo
soltanto un mese fa -
pensate, solo nel 2022,
14 anni dopo l'Ecuador -
che un ecosistema europeo
ha visto riconosciuti i suoi diritti.
Questa volta si tratta di una laguna,
si chiama Mar Menor, si trova in Spagna
ed è il nostro primo ecosistema
tutelato da diritti.
Secondo me è una svolta fondamentale
che finalmente ci rimetterà
un po' in carreggiata
con quanto sta succedendo nel mondo.
Ma la mia speranza -
perché la natura, sapete,
è un concetto molto generale.
E questi concetti
così generali, un po' astratti,
alla fine sono anche difficili
da comprendere e applicare.
Allora la mia speranza è che,
siccome la natura alla fine è fatta
per oltre l'80% di piante,
e di esseri viventi fatti
in un certo modo,
noi potremo fare un passo in avanti;
e quindi riconoscere,
anziché i diritti degli ecosistemi,
o i diritti generici della natura,
i diritti di quegli esseri viventi
che fino adesso non ne hanno avuti,
che sono le piante.
Perché i diritti, fino a oggi -
pensate ai diritti
del fanciullo, nel 1924;
ai diritti dell'uomo,
dopo la Seconda Guerra Mondiale;
o ai diritti delle donne,
dopo millenni di sfruttamento;
ai diritti dei neri,
o a tanti altri diritti
che ancora non sono stati riconosciuti:
in genere vengono riconosciuti
in funzione riparatoria.
Cioè qualcuno si accorge -
la società, noi tutti -
che c'è stato un torto grosso,
in genere una guerra,
e quindi i diritti
sono una fonte di pagamento,
una fonte di riparazione di questo danno.
Ora, quale guerra peggiore
di quella che stiamo combattendo da secoli
contro esseri viventi indifesi, gentili,
che in più ci aiutano:
ripuliscono la nostra acqua,
ripuliscono la nostra aria,
ripuliscono i nostri suoli,
ci fanno vivere meglio,
ci danno ombra, ci danno fresco,
ospitano le altre specie viventi.
Quale guerra più inutile
e insensata c'è, di questa?
E quale maggiore necessità c'è,
che riparare questo torto?
E allora, perché nessuno
se n'è mai occupato fino adesso?
Perché ho il privilegio di essere stata
la prima persona a fare questa proposta?
Perché noi siamo tutti quanti
un po' malati -
passatemi questo termine,
ma non è mio, è dei ricercatori -
di una "plant blindness",
cioè noi siamo ciechi
di fronte alle piante.
È una "malattia" - chiamiamola così,
tra molte virgolette - di tipo evolutivo.
Noi non vediamo le piante
perché non ci è mai servito
difenderci dalle piante.
Le piante non ci hanno mai attaccato,
non sono mai state un pericolo.
E quindi noi, se guardiamo un'immagine
con una bella foresta e una scimmietta,
e ci chiedono cosa vediamo,
diciamo: "Vedo una scimmia",
e magari ci sono
altre 100 forme di vita lì,
che sono tutte quante di tipo vegetale,
e noi neanche le abbiamo notate.
Pensate che questa cosa qui
adesso cerchiamo addirittura di curarla.
In alcune università si sta curando,
si sta cercando di capire come fare.
Io non so come fare: vi posso raccontare
cosa è successo a me.
Io, a un certo punto, ho preso
il mio secondo dottorato di ricerca
in Scienze Agrarie e Ambientali,
e sono finita a studiare
l'intelligenza delle piante.
E lì mi sono accorta
che questi esseri viventi -
che come a tanti di voi,
fino a quel momento,
erano sembrati - sì, belli,
si studia a scuola che sono vivi;
ma insomma, niente con cui
realmente entrare in contatto -
invece sono straordinari:
comunicano tra loro, imparano,
memorizzano, dormono.
Riconoscono i parenti.
Fanno tantissime cose,
adesso non voglio farvi l'elenco,
veramente incredibili,
e alle quali neanche pensiamo.
Addirittura esiste la possibilità,
anche se non abbiamo ancora
tutti quanti gli elementi per affermarlo,
che le piante possano
perfino sentire dolore.
Parrebbe che ci siano delle strutture
in grado di trasmettere
questo tipo di messaggi,
questo tipo di informazioni.
Il punto è che, se qualcuno ci chiede
se le piante soffrono o no,
non possiamo rispondere no.
L'unica risposta corretta,
scientificamente fondata, è "non lo so".
E allora, se noi non lo sappiamo,
quello che dobbiamo fare è comportarci
come se le piante potessero soffrire.
E sebbene io non sia del tutto convinta
che il dolore sia un criterio per decidere
chi debba avere diritti e chi no,
in ogni caso non è un criterio
per escludere nessuno.
Al contrario, includere le piante
nel nostro processo democratico
non farà altro che migliorare
il mondo in cui siamo.
E riflettendo su questi argomenti,
vi lascio con uno spunto di curiosità.
Riflettendo su questi argomenti,
un artista concettuale
che si chiama Jonathon Keats,
negli Stati Uniti ha proposto
questo esperimento
che riguarda due banane, due come noi.
Ha creato questi due set sperimentali.
Sapete che sempre, negli esperimenti,
si fa un set di controllo,
quindi nel vaso che vedete di sinistra
non succede niente, c'è solo una banana.
E infatti è la control unit,
l'unità di controllo.
Nell'unità due c'è invece la banana test.
Ora, questo esperimento si basa sul fatto
che quando le piante vengono stressate
emettono un ormone.
Ne emettono vari:
ma quello più noto che ha
a che fare con le banane
è l'etilene.
Allora, Keats ha pensato
che se noi, in una di queste due unità,
lasciamo una banana a maturare
con i suoi ritmi normali,
e se nell'altra mettiamo,
insieme alla banana, una pianta,
ed esponiamo questa pianta
alle condizioni di vita
alle quali si troverebbe esposta,
o si troverà esposta in seguito
a una determinata politica -
per esempio, diciamo che decidiamo
di non fare nulla
contro i cambiamenti climatici,
e quindi noi immaginiamo
come sarà il clima
nei prossimi 20 o 30 anni.
Qual è la condizione di umidità,
quale è la condizione di temperatura,
quale è la condizione
di inquinamento dell'aria, eccetera -
e ricreiamo quella situazione
all'interno dell'unità
dove ci sono la pianta e il barattolo.
Se la pianta si stressa,
la banana maturerà più in fretta;
e in questo modo,
la pianta avrà avuto modo
di esprimere il suo parere
rispetto a quella politica.
Ora, naturalmente, è molto presto insomma,
siamo di là da venire
al fatto che le piante
possano effettivamente votare.
Ma immaginate che mondo migliore,
più bello e più giusto sarà
quando l'80% di tutto quello
che è vivo sul pianeta
potrà godere anch'esso di diritti.
(Applausi)